hey there townscapers
hope y'all are doing okay today um today
i just wanted to come out and show you
the tour for chapter three of connecting
small towns
i'll start uploading chapter four
sometime this week but until then i hope
y'all can enjoy what i got going on in
chapter three
because i finally mastered staircases if
you haven't noticed i've gone staircase
crazy
um and i slightly have a better
understanding of cranes but it's
something that i'm still working on so
that's pretty cool
uh but before we get started i just
wanted to thank you all for coming by
and showing me some love
this week i really appreciate it this
channel is doing really really well and
of course it's because of all of you so
thank you again please keep doing what
you're doing and i'll continue to do my
thing as well
if you haven't already please hit that
subscribe button and make sure that you
like and comment because it helps me out
a lot
as i stated in previous tour episodes
this series is pretty much me just
connecting small towns i'm practicing
and i'm trying to get better so you'll
see me gradually improve throughout this
series um if you have seen some of my
footage already this video is going to
feature some buildings that you may
recognize
these are going to come from sessions 13
through 17. if you haven't seen them or
you just want to view them again
the playlist is going to be in the upper
right corner of this video in a card
along with some asmr videos which is one
of my popular series
um a couple of tips and tricks videos
and my random clicking playlist
please be sure to check out those cards
as there's some really really good stuff
in there
if you do like it hit the like button
and share with your fellow youtube
friends
i would really appreciate it but anyways
that's all for me
enjoy the video and please make sure
that you like and subscribe
and i just want to thank y'all for doing
such because you guys are really helping
me out and i'll see you next time
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
stars
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey there townscaper if you're hearing
this and that means you made it to the
end i just want to thank you so much for
viewing it's greatly appreciated make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
make sure you hit that like button
because that will help me out a lot
also you can follow me on instagram and
twitter the links are down in the
description below
and again i just want to say thank you
so much for checking in and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you